obviously there's a lot of talk about
how you are the first black lead on the
show how diverse is your group of
contestants gonna be and how diverse do
you want it to be well I don't get to
see them before I'll be seeing them the
first time when they come out the limo
which I'm very excited about do I hope
that there's diversity in the cast
absolutely no I don't just date a
specific race I date everyone I'm open
to everyone and so I'm hoping to see a
cast that reflects that as well and I've
told them that how much do you think
that that will be a discussion that you
have with the guys in the house I mean
everybody's talking about you being the
first black elite how much will you talk
to them about it
um I always say I get talking about it
initially it's first it's something that
should be talked about I'm happy to
address it I'm honored to be the first
with the guys you know if it's something
new to them then I want to talk about it
the same way that I talk to think about
it you know have you ever dated a black
woman before I'll talk about my
experiences as well you know it's about
me too but I don't want it to be
something that defines our relationship
but I think it's something that's
important to address
you